au monde première pour le football
montpelliérain laurent blanc le milieu
de terrain l'homme peut se fera ses
débuts ce soir avec l'équipe de france
contre l'eire c'est un aboutissement
dans la jeune carrière de blanc qui
paraît-il garde la tête froide
à 23 ans la lisière laurent blanc un
gaillard de 1 mètre 90 crève l'écran du
football français allez après leur
sélection j'étais super motivé son choix
et je passe un savon desservir le numéro
8 du mps est le meilleur buteur de son
équipe en 24 matchs il a trouvé à onze
reprises les filets adverses samedi soir
contre lens il est devenu le troisième
artificier du championnat de france
je me dis tu aurais pu remarquer
quelques uns de plus et là je crois que
ce soit sans être prétentieux je crois
que de plus j'aurais pu effacer contre
l'équipe nordiste blanc était le
meilleur élément montpelliérain il a
sorti le mps et de la grisaille
fini les doutes dans la tête ça va très
bien façon ça va très bien dans les
jeunes ça va très bien aussi
je crois que j'ai pas envie de coucher
ce soir
et je crois que ce match m'a fait du
bien physiquement parce que bon c'est la
reprise est pour beaucoup certains
joueurs donc encore un petit peu de
compétition ont toujours d'être
sélectionné en équipe de france ça a été
mon cas l'état je suis à 0 et le plus
dur commence pour moi c'est à dire
confirmé les connaître les choix qui ont
été faits sont exacts c'est toujours
ennuyeux pour le joueur donc je suis pas
d'exception c'est plus ce moment il faut
pas foule à gauche formé à montpellier
blanc rapporter tous les maillots des
bleus en levant avec les espoirs le
championnat d'europe en 88 ce soir à
dublin
lolo le footballeur discret et sierra de
séduire
il en a les moyens